You know that old joke about women being too tired for sex?
Turns out, it's not just an excuse.
[INTRO MUSIC]
Hey, everyone. Julia here for DNews.
Not getting enough sleep really screws you up.
You can't remember things as well.
You can't focus.
You might make some pretty poor decisions.
You get the picture.
Really we've talked about it before!
Check out some links down below.
But it seems not getting enough sleep,
even screws up your screwing.
Yeah, okay, it sounds like a "no duh" kind of thing
But there really haven't been any studies on this
in women until now.
A somewhat small study published in the Journal
Sexual Medicine
found that women who slept more
were more likely to have sex.
The study asked 171 female college students
about their sleep and sexual habits.
Most of the women were straight, and about half of them were in relationships.
The results seems to focus mostly on those groups.
Every morning they filled out a questiomnaire, that asked questions like
how long did it take you to fall asleep, and have you had sex in the last 24 hours?
The researchers found that for each extra hour of sleep the women had
they were hornier, and had 14% increase in the likelihood of sex the next day.
Even after factoring for things like age, sexual problems, fatigue or menstruation.
But not only did they get more action the next day, they performed better.
Women who slept more, also reported more vaginal lubrication during sex
than those who didn't sleep as much.
This does seem like common sense, but scientists still aren't sure on why this is.
The researchers think that maybe poor sleep messes with a women hormone levels that quote:
And gentlemen I'm not letting you off the hook either, you need your, sleep too.
A study published in the Journal of American Medical Association
found that men who don't get enough sleep, have testosterone levels closer to a man fifteen years older
even after just one week's worth of poor sleep.
That lowering of testosterone leaves men feeling less in the mood.
So ladies and gents
if you wanna get some, get some sleep.
Speaking of sleep if you want to know more about sleep and why we need it, check out this playlist down here
to watch all of our videos
about how important it really is.
Alright guys, do you have any questions about the weird way our body works?
Leave them in the comments below
and maybe we'll make a video about it!
Until then, hit those like and subscribe buttons so you can get more DNews every day of the week.
[OUTRO MUSIC]